we will finish our discussion of
classical statistical methods by
discussing a general method for
estimation the so called maximum
likelihood method if an unknown
parameter can be expressed as an
expectation we have seen that there is a
natural way of estimating it but what if
this is not the case suppose there is no
apparent way of interpreting theta as an
expectation so we need to do something
else so rather than using this approach
we will use a different approach which
is the following we will find a value of
theta that makes the data that we have
seen most likely that is we will find
the value of theta under which the
probability of obtaining the particular
X that we have seen that probability is
as large as possible and that value of
theta is going to be our estimate the
maximum likelihood estimate here I wrote
a PMF that's what you would do if X was
a discrete random variable but the same
procedure of course applies when X is a
continuous random variable and more
generally this procedure also applies
when X is a vector of observations and
when theta is a vector of parameters but
what does this method really do it is
instructive to compare maximum
likelihood estimation to a Bayesian
approach in a Bayesian setting what we
do is we find the posterior distribution
of the unknown parameter which is now
treated as a random variable and then we
look for the most likely value of theta
this we look at this distribution and
try to find its peak so we want to
maximize this quantity over theta the
denominator does not involve any Thetas
so we ignore it and suppose now that we
use a prior for theta which is flat
suppose that this prior is constant over
the range of possible values of theta in
that case what we need to do
is to just take this expression and
maximize it over all Thetas and this
looks very similar to what is happening
here where we take this expression and
maximize it over all Thetas so
operationally maximum likelihood
estimation is the same as Bayesian
estimation in which we find the peak of
the posterior for the special case where
we're using a constant or flat crier but
despite this similarity the two methods
are philosophically very different in
the Bayesian setting you're asking the
question what is the most likely value
of theta who arez in the maximum
likelihood setting you're asking what is
the value of theta that makes my data
most likely or what is the value of
theta under which my data are the least
surprising so the interpretation of the
two methods is quite different even
though the mechanics can be fairly
similar the maximum likelihood method
has some remarkable properties that we
would like now to discuss but first one
comment we need to take the probability
of the observed data given theta this is
a function of theta and maximize it over
theta in some problems we can find
closed form solutions for the optimal
value of theta which is going to be our
estimate but more often and especially
for large problems one has to do this
maximization in a numerical way this is
possible these days and routinely people
solve very high dimensional problems
with lots of data and lots of parameters
using the maximum likelihood methodology
the maximum likelihood methodology is
very popular because it has a very sound
theoretical basis I will list a few
facts which we will not attempt to prove
or even justify but they're useful to
know as general background
suppose that we have n pieces of data
that are drawn from a model from a
certain structure then under mild
assumptions the maximum likelihood
estimator has the property that it is
consistent that is as we draw more and
more data our estimate is going to
converge to the true value of the
parameter in addition we know quite a
bit more asymptotically the maximum
likelihood estimator behaves like a
normal random variable that is after we
normalize subtract the target and divide
by its standard deviation it approaches
a standard normal distribution so in
this sense it behaves the same way that
the sample mean behaves notice that this
expression here involves the standard
error of the maximum likelihood
estimator this is an important quantity
and for this reason people have
developed either analytical or
simulation methods for calculating or
approximating this standard error once
you have an estimate or an approximation
of the standard error in your hands you
can further use it to construct
confidence intervals using the
asymptotic normality then we can
construct the confidence interval in
exactly the same way as we did for the
case of the sample mean estimator and
this for example would be a 95%
confidence interval finally one last
important property is that the maximum
likelihood estimator is what is called
an asymptotically efficient estimator
that is it is the best possible
estimator in the sense that it achieves
the smallest possible variance so all
these are very strong properties and
this is the reason why maximum
likelihood estimation is the most common
approach for problems that do not have
any particular special structure that
you can exploit otherwise